and the sun beams down on
san martin splashing into the show
welcome to the big leagues the major
league debut his minor league numbers
well raver is another guy that's coming
up through the system and you can see
the control not many walks 28 walks 112
strikeouts and that's what he's going to
have to do
at this level
in the center field
delano
almost 470 against the reds
and he goes down on strikes
[Applause]
first major league strikeout
switch hitting brian reynolds
in the big leagues in one inning
nobody's hitting back-to-back strikeouts
in a perfect first inning for the san
martin overton has an era now first time
we've had seen him with one of those
yeah in triple a and in his time in the
major leagues with toronto and the
pirates
he'd gone about two months without
allowing a run and india is aboard with
a lead-off single here's max schrock
schrock
in the left center
india to third base
stop sign there schrock plunges head
first into second with a double the reds
have second and third with nobody out
castiano standing in
castillanos to center reynolds back
that'll get the run in
both runners tag
truck to third india scores sac fly rbi
reds lead one nothing the batter is joey
votto vado has not played the last
couple of days he jammed his knee a
little bit
[Applause]
in the air
left field offered back
and the team lead at rbi seesaw's back
to joey bottle
a three-nothing rebs lead
the reds have scored three times in the
first inning have a three-nothing lead
five hits
and there it is
center field wave on at third
suarez to the plate rbi line drive
single by tucker barnhart and the reds
sought their advantage for nothing under
overton a one-two pitch swinging a miss
struck him out in a fastball and the
reds have an inning nine
to the plate four score anthony alford
now hitting 219 with five homers 10 runs
batted in
that is hit out to left center and
alford can run he's going to put on the
brakes though do shields getting that
ball in so a long single for all three
kevin newman having a tough time on the
road trip he's four for 29. 1-2
centerfield to shields
two scoreless innings for san martin
eugenio suarez leads off for the reds
third inning they're leading four to
nothing
weekly hit but that's how it's wow
suarez has called out on a close play
wow i was gonna say that's how suarez's
month has gone he's been able to buy
some of those but good play
ranging wow just got wow cool tucker
there will be a lot of decisions made in
the off season as there always are but
with a younger team
more than
most newman
as the final out so cody potts a couple
of scoreless hittings in relief nothing
cincinnati draver sound martine who has
been
pretty good at one hitter so far a
one-two pitch
and a swing and a miss down on strikes
tsutsugo and that is five strikeouts for
braver san martin struck out colin moran
on a payoff looking
being that it's his major league debut
now we're getting some ground balls
getting settled in getting back down to
the bottom of the strike zone four
scoreless for san martin more first
inning runs
bounced over the mound backhanded by the
second baseman newman throws across nice
play by newman sun martin not slow and
was thrown out on top of the order
jonathan india
india to left field
over the leap of offer
another extra base hit jonathan india is
three for three now nick castellanos the
only reds position player in the lineup
without a hit so far
castillanos to center
reynolds the glove india tags it third
another rbi for nick castellanos his
second sac fly of the day and he ties
joey bottle for the team lead in ribbies
motto's got a two run homer today popped
out as last time runner goes
[Applause]
destroys it to right
a two home run day and four reminisce
for joseph daniel
sammy you don't like to see the ball hit
that far i i
that was an absolutely
bomb that was a hundred and ten off the
bat 466
feet
seven nothing reds and a eugenio suarez
that's 29 for suarez gino's approach
this entire month has been really good
and when they make a mistake he makes
them back taylor davis now pirates
catcher
gets away from the gold glover barnhart
and alfred in standing scoring
pirates are on the board in the fifth
he's lined out twice once to center the
other time to right
took a bound on suarez second one
double play now colin moran will bat
with runners at second and third and two
out
just out of the zone a walk to moran the
base is loaded and reluctantly david
bell pops up from his seat that's gonna
be all for san martin i'm sure the fans
not happy that santa martin's getting
lifted but i gotta think they'll reward
him with a nice applause here deservedly
so alford's score to the pirates only
run on a wild pitch by sandovar team
struck him out
warren does the job and leaves him
loading san martin's debut five and two
thirds one run thanks in part to his
reliever teammate and john the win has
picked up a little bit castellanos hits
a ball left of center even to the
bullpen area could get some help
castellanos to left center that's got
some carrie reynolds back and it's gone
there's a new career high home runs in
four straight games for castillanos
well india's had himself a pretty good
day see if he can keep that rolling
india high in the air deep left field
his first career for his day
and what another great swing
here's the pitcher shelby miller
bare hand near the bag long throw a lead
tag down got him
how did they do that well sheldon miller
shuts it down but geno continues to play
[Music]
ground ball
a rout for the reds concludes the home
slate on this regular season and
guarantees the red legs a winning year
you